hi guys hi this is super fun it's a
one-girl five gays really and on et
Canada bride this is cool thanks for
coming in and what I love is I sent you
guys kind of a group mass email and
within maybe seven minutes you were all
like I'm in on their count me and
there's no bad blood between any of you
which is grown well I mean this show was
huge it was massive
and in 2009 it premiered which was ten
years ago that's crazy like ten years
ago
looking back ten years ago did you have
any idea what the show was gonna do for
your lives absolutely not we filmed it
in a dark basement and if you remember
the first few episodes we all just spoke
over top of one another and then
eventually they figured out how to make
us talk one at a time and then success
and sued it was it went everywhere and
people watched it all the time it was a
different time everyone had cable yeah
people made a real ritual out of the
show wouldn't alone people told me all
the time that they would watch it on
Friday night while like pre-drinking
pre-gaming yeah and I mean what the show
did obviously it was a representation of
the lgbtq+ community but it's so funny
because even telling people that you
were coming in today like the amount of
people I did what you watch that show
like I just were you guys surprised by
the amount of fanfare that the show
received we'd rate guys to like my
girlfriend maybe watch it and they just
love it this is so cool they know every
frame right yeah
I think they think because it aired on
MTV Canada it was cool right and that
was the era of like the Oscar show and
the hills and Jersey Shore and so
automatically you know it was cool to be
on MTV and I think having gay in the
title really made a huge difference
because it sort of made gay cool as well
by being on MTV Canada so for us it was
amazing because so many people watch it
we get we always get messages and hear
from people being like I used to watch
it in my basement underneath a cover
listing for my parents upstairs to like
see if they were coming down and then I
turn the channel or I'd like you know
turn off the laptop and it's like it was
really powerful for people because I
think people hadn't seen themselves in
this
before right I also think it was a
different kind of fandom I wouldn't even
call them fans I think that this was
before like YouTube really kicked in and
though these kind of content was like it
still is very organic and very raw so
for us I think while we were filming it
it felt very natural we were hanging out
with friends we were not thinking of the
good final product true and then when we
saw how it affected people because
they're really connected with us in a
much more organic level like people do
today with the YouTube stars so you had
that real like kind of connection with
people when they came up to talk to you
the time we had no idea actually watched
it like I'll get it does suck that when
people were like I was just in
elementary school okay but when it
started like we had no clue what we were
even doing their drinks and talking to
our friends blue what it was when it
started and then it became a thing so
like like wama thing like it was really
organic to start and then it sort of
became that people are like oh I'm
seeing myself on TV for the first time
or I'm seeing what my future could look
like for the first time on TV and it was
really powerful for people it was super
powerful and I mean it's crazy again
2009 that's when grinder came out was -
you guys all said yes right away when
was the last time the five of you were
in a room together obviously you keep in
touch now yeah it's much easier because
of zip specifically uh it's a while
maybe your party probably some timer we
want you Michael towards a very iconic
gay party there's a lot of us so we see
each other a lot but this five that's
what I'm so excited it's a good time you
picked a good five yeah I mean I don't
want to offend anyone but it's been
great we'll take the OG five that's
right I mean we love everybody who was
on the show
I'm interested to hear what was the
casting process for the series because I
heard like people were getting poached
out at woodys on church how did each of
you become to take part in the series
well David and I were on the first ever
episode and it was we were kind of asked
to do this thing we had no clue what it
was gonna be
originally the show was kind of like oh
it's gonna be like straight people
offering other straight people advice
and then it became like gay guys
offering straight people advice and then
it became just gay guys talking about
their lives right and so we were on the
first ever one and then sort of people
either auditioned or were asked to be a
part of it like slowly but surely I
remember I bet your producer action was
like it's just gonna be you five and
then one new person I'm like okay no I
was actually on MTV's the after show and
I remember Garrett our exec producer
came up and one day said you know would
you be willing to talk about sex on TV
and I thought oh my god I don't know but
right you know like you watch that first
annual yeah but yeah it's crazy and then
we started we would suggest um friends
of ours but they would hold open
castings I have a member I want because
of you I think you took to Karen and I
went in and I remember it was not part
of the kitchen and I wasn't I'm not
really good at auditioning that's not
what I do and I showed up and I remember
II was a roomful of like Gabe screaming
on top of each other get on TV but I
remember being like so like who didn't
know for me and I just like sat back and
was so quiet and probably said like
three really like funny things and then
they called me back the next day and I
was like what I couldn't imagine any of
you I really couldn't either
I mean II hate people who talk about
what they did today and like a gym guys
all they do is they're gay they do I
detected a what did you do I'm like you
all I hate you it's a lot of anger
I auditioned on a Friday and then I shot
my first episode of The Sunday Paul a
doctor saw I was a fan-made on the show
I would love to know what each of you
are up to now because obviously we can
find you on social media but I'm gonna
start in the back with you in if you
want to tell me what are you up to now
right right now I'm on a radio station
called 102.1 the edge it's an
alternative station here in Toronto and
I'm a writer for the station as well and
it on your personality so I just I still
talk I just don't have to look good
anymore how about you I should probably
start with I'm engaged
he's so cute
- Ellie is the parrot is my own PR
agency so getting that started good like
not even many wife is good oh yeah don't
undersell yourself you have an ardour
but yeah we're doing a lot of that card
festivals and such so exciting
that's awesome how about you David yeah
I mean things couldn't be more different
for me
you know I this is the first sort of
television thing I've done since I
handle all the digital marketing for
Canada's biggest bank started my own
little marketing company on the side and
yeah I'm boring now but honestly I still
stand by it was smart enough to do at
the time I had my like I would sell what
I wore on there so there's this hideous
you know ISIL honey and I made that like
you sold like you socks no you shirts
you do with Canadian TV yeah so that's
all thing me I needed the coin all right
but no now I'm in finance yeah much more
secure yeah gotta get that pension honey
and Philip I've worked in marketing and
television sort of back and forth for a
long time in my 20s I'm 30 now and I
sort of have just like I'm focusing on
me so I'm doing a lot of this is so
disgusting like brand deals and
influencer work and I'm the pop culture
expert on the global morning show
they represent that's awesome and it's
all disgusting don't say that public
figures I'm working I've a new show on
out TV called fried so it's just pretty
weird lot speed
that's awesome tell me about the show of
it so the show basically is sort of
about queer history LGBTQ history in
different cities as they celebrate pride
in the present so basically last year we
did episodes in New York and Calgary and
Berlin and Hong Kong and Salt Lake City
and we're about to launch a second
season and a third season is coming we
got renewed for two more seasons that
you went to that you were like just
blown away by that you never expected to
be as massive as it was well it was
really cool I got to walk with the
Canadian embassy in in Berlin during
Pride there and it was really
interesting learning a lot about the
clear history in Berlin because it feels
like if the world war hadn't happened
like are the global queer movement would
have been so much further ahead so just
learning a lot about that history and
it's been so I opening for me to go to
these places and get to like celebrate
pride in 2018 or 2019 but learn and be
connected to so much history LGBT
history and in particular so that's been
really an amazing experience so check us
out on TV you were always good about
bringing that type of information in
queer history to one or five gays event
which I thought was cool yeah it's
important to remember where we all
plural absolutely yeah all of us can
just talk about being gay on television
so yeah important yeah I can do that
though okay so this show there was you
guys said a lot of things were pretty
racy I'm going to go through them right
having your parents and maybe friends
watch this or any of you mortified by
anything you saw every week I would be
mortified by something that I said and I
we can over it but like I said some
stupid thing my mom would always have it
should have a if there was like a
question that was asked about our sex
lives she would have like sort of a
technique if she would do she would like
turn the channel for a minute she'd be
like he's brilliant he's funny he's
enlightening people and then she would
like turn it back to the channel cuz she
didn't need to know about stuff about my
parents watch this is a game you'd be
like oh god so cool now what's this what
does that mean I was like don't worry
better that and I use if it was really
bad I would be like oh I just said that
wasn't even true but like right yeah I
know as well as I was saying that - yeah
always my parents and my grandma even
watched it and they would like my
grandma one time said to me she's like I
think that piece you said about
masturbating was really I was like oh
god how did you see that but my parents
were pretty liberal so your parents are
cool yeah they're not no higher my
technique was just like I'd never watch
the show so you wouldn't know I was too
cool I throw parties now some people
don't like to watch themselves know and
I also didn't want to remember what I
had set up a bear or he didn't like stay
with me you know doesn't say it in front
of the camera and I would not revisit it
didn't want I remember couldn't remember
like an episode this morning yeah anyway
is there anything any of you regret from
your time on the show I don't regret not
anymore
no way being involved I'm not being on
the show maybe some interactions you had
with people like is there anything that
looking back now you're like okay that
was there were a few we were pretty
careless I think with things that we
said like about we never grow up it mean
we really gonna hurt ya we were I don't
know if the tone of that show would
translate sometimes into 20/20 like it
was a little fish
I'm joshing a couple episodes we're in a
dark room with friends having jury uh
yeah I think was the magic of the show
it did honestly feel like I think we
couldn't even see the cameras I always
felt like and I was sort of known for
like getting in fights with people on
that show but I was quite like I was
kind of holding my own and kind of
making feet like holding people
accountable for what they said there
were so many people of like for you know
older generations who didn't have a
platform we did and I just felt like we
had a responsibility to those people to
like really speak with purpose and and
and responsibility and I don't know I
just thought like when people were fat
but it said stupid things or offensive
things like I was gonna hold them
accountable well I mean people have to
be held accountable yeah their actions
and their words and at that it's the
same as it is today right and I thought
they're also responsible for a lot of
younger people than us as well I think a
lot of times the first gay people a lot
of young people in Canada and the US
ever saw speak so freely about their
sexuality were us so I think we did have
our responsibility there as well can I
say that was a good point when the show
started airing in the US I remember
thinking okay you know same-sex marriage
wasn't legal at that time so there was a
lot of nuances that I thought you know
we have to be a little more respectful
to but struggle is still going on
certainly around the world but in the US
as well so I remember not editing myself
for thinking we need to be more
understanding that there's even you know
there could be even a different struggle
in the u.s. for some of these yeah and
we have a place of privilege yeah huge
place of privilege to have this platform
like we are lucky we live in a big city
that where there's an entire suite of
gay bars but some people live in tiny
towns and they're the only LGBT
identified person in their town the only
gay in the village so for us it was like
it was like we had to you know we had to
reach them and let them know that like
their life you know if it does get
better in their life you know they're
like not yeah when the show wrapped and
it all ended I think which time the time
we don't fight let's not let's just say
when the show was done was it you guys
were famous like you guys are nobody you
love this it was creative we got famous
we were no I don't think no we were yes
exactly when ad and TV famous which I
mean is still being recognized that
Walmart hosts be yes
[Laughter]
so you guys I mean there was people that
you know would recognize you on the
street what were they saying when they
came up in my favor it had to be coming
from from from work and he was like a 13
hour work day and somebody walked up to
me and said like oh my god you're Kuan I
can't believe you take the subway yeah I
was ready to like punch that person I
was so mad I was thinking what money are
you gonna buy me a car they totally
brother recognizability is over nobody
mean like like people think you because
you're on TV they're like just famous at
the time when people would come up to us
I would always just get I love your show
right now I sort of got everyone that
does that it's the most beautiful
stories I get you know yeah I'm I get
you saved my leg or your show save the
leg that's what we get now and that's
what's so cool like and the leaf expect
the boner you never expect you're on it
work yeah and you have to meet somebody
and then somebody walks up to you and
they literally just makes me cry it was
really powerful for people we had not
been we again we had no idea how the
time how much we were influencing other
people because a lot of these um viewers
were the young and skilled at home now
they're coming into the world and
they're like you know we're working with
them or you meet them at parties and
then they tell you these things and I'm
like wow yeah yes every weekend I go out
it's getting meaner with all gay guys in
the city with our show and I'm sorry
getting et here because like I feel like
I do you think it's like how do you see
the show exactly yeah and it's not I can
never see anything it's this it's this
idea of someone like myself who is an
act like sort of an outrageous
flamboyant man that somehow this is an
act
how this is this is outrageous
performance is authentic I'd say that I
love Streisand you get sticking through
like are these gay income tell me that
it's a case stereotype and I'm trying to
like fulfill a role
I thought for a second because one chick
came out to me the street came out
bartending and he's like hey are you the
Atlantic like 15 with his dad like that
I want you to know I'm straight but
you've made your show and you guys have
made on things like
[Music]
and people are still watching this
series I was going through watching
episodes on YouTube and going through
the comments of people like still here
in 2019 people are still enjoying it
I'll never forget one time when I was
you know on one girl five gays but also
waiting tables five six days a week
I was waiting tables and this young girl
said to me no offense but you look like
Yein from one sort of the show and then
the next morning I be at the CBC like
changing garbages like are you from that
show I'm like move I'm garbage if they
wanted to do a reboot in 2020 would each
of you be game to do this all over again
no liar liar liar I think you serious I
said no yeah I don't believe you came to
the bit let him explain why not I just
think like I did what I was good during
that period doing this I think that it's
for me okay I love that I love what it
did and I loved what is it for me and
for other people but I'm like mid-30s
now and I'm kind of boring at to be
honest like it would be so for the show
rebooted I think it I think it could be
really meaningful for people I'd love to
see like a new cast and I'd like to see
like a really diverse casts I'd love to
see people from all under the acronym
because I think that you know we were
really important for sort of like a gay
education a decade ago but I think that
now there's like a larger education
about all LGBT yeah q+ issues that have
to happen so I'd love to see a reboot
happen but just with like a different
kind
there was visibility I think that was
missing back in 2000 you know you look
at that show now from that to basic
point of view and I'm like it still is
so radical and the casting of the show
is so interest being compared to a lot
of faith especially
Media and it's getting better now which
will look like Paul with him touch but
overall it's been a very white but like
I don't know if I'm willing grace is all
I had growing up I think we're around
the same age but our show I'm hoping
anger than most of you guys so I don't
know being film in Toronto to like had
somebody from every like ethnicity and
background and body size and and that
was like it still looks very cool you
know why I would question doing it again
I don't know if you guys agree I can
there were twice twice in almost four
years we'll be doing the show where I
would get like a troll comment I mean
comment yeah that's my point is to in
four years that culture is like a new
thing about like trolling and being the
guy friends leave my boyfriend's on
Dancing with the Stars now and just
getting trolled for no reason and I'm
think I'm way too sensitive for that so
I would question it but come on everyone
loved it yeah you get one from the
original cast and then you get like a
younger diverse cast per episode yeah
that's like a nice wide og per episode
oh it's like 100 G for games yeah one
girl 100 G for game yeah yeah well thank
you guys for joining me and hopefully
maybe a reboot thank you so much thanks
for letting yeah thanks guys
[Music]